Dolores Claiborne was directed by Taylor
Hackford and stars Kathy Bates in the
title role and Jennifer Jason Leigh and
is based off of Stephen King's book
which was told entirely from the first
person and it's about a woman the title
character played by Bates who's the
housemaid of a very rich and wealthy
older woman who dies in the opening
scene and Claybourne is highly suspected
to be the murderer and Christopher
Plummer is the detective who's trying to
close this case because he has a grudge
against Claybourne from a similar case
many years in the past and Lee plays the
daughter of Claybourne who comes back to
her hometown for the first time in many
years and struggles with a lot of really
hard things that happened to her and her
mother in the past the structure of the
film is that were thrown into the very
harsh reality of these characters
present-day lives and it's not until the
end of the film that we understand how
they got to that place and we understand
that by a long series of flashbacks that
are interwoven pretty much seamlessly
throughout this story Dolores Claiborne
is one of the more overlooked King
adaptations of the 90s it came out in
1995 right after Shawshank Redemption it
is one of Stephen King's 10 favorite
adaptations of his work and a lot of the
greatness of this movie comes from Kathy
Bates powerhouse performance she won the
Oscar for misery but she wasn't even
nominated for this movie and after
seeing a lot of her work this is my
favorite role of hers in fact it's Bates
favorite role that she's ever done she
is so marvelous in this movie because
she doesn't feel like she's acting she
so fully embodies this character of this
broken bitter woman who has seen so much
and been through so much and I didn't
look at her and see Kathy Bates the
famous actress I just saw Dolores
Claiborne she is so magnificent in this
role and it's definitely one of the more
overlooked works in her career this is
one of the rare Stephen King films that
isn't about monsters ghosts vampires
there's nothing terribly horrific going
on in this movie of a supernatural sense
it is however very scary in a dramatic
sense this could be considered a
psychological thriller because a lot
the past sequences involved the severe
trauma that David Strathairn who plays
the husband and father inflicted on his
family he is disgusting as a human being
and he really sold that in his
performance this movie is a fantastic
work just for the performances alone you
can watch this film and just look at it
from an acting perspective and learn a
lot but from a directing and editing
perspective you can learn even more
Taylor Hackford who has since made films
like Ray as I already said seamlessly
blended the past and the present to
create something that felt true to its
characters and their story it didn't
feel like direction and editing as the
showcase like look at all these amazing
things I can do with the camera and look
at these amazing ways that I can show
you the story he never lost sight of the
characters in his film and they're
always at the forefront I'm not gonna
get into any spoilers in this review
because over the years this has actually
become one of the least talked about
Stephen King adaptations I think it's
flown under a lot of people's radars
sure tons have seen it obviously but
it's never really mentioned in the same
breath as other great Stephen King
dramas like Shawshank or The Green Mile
granted that's probably because it's not
as good as those films but that doesn't
mean this dump should go overlooked I
was so wrapped up in the story and the
characters of this film that I was very
happy watching this movie despite the
very somber and depressing story it's
just nice to see a film with fully
realized characters where you can invest
yourself in their lives
and the story is thrilling while having
no action sequences of any kind if
you've never seen Dolores Claiborne I
would highly recommend checking it out
there is as I know no blu-ray yet and I
can't wait to get one whenever it
finally is released but I did watch it
on Amazon video it's available there in
HD so if you want to see it in this
highest quality I think that's your best
bet as of now so definitely check out
this movie if you get a chance as for
flaws I would say the last 15 minutes
can start to drag a little bit it's
building to something very climactic and
very powerful and I think if they had
trimmed it down and honed it down a
little better it would have had more
impact there's also some
very crowd-pleasing moments that felt a
little stereotypical towards the end but
it was still satisfying I'm gonna give
Dolores Claiborne and a - as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]